[Applause]
Merry Christmas
you you guys know how to make a lady
feel welcome
okay where do we begin
I wish it was like the book so this is
my copy uh-huh and as you know on this
show we've tried to build something that
is
uh Whiplash comedy at one moment because
we all need to laugh yeah and it's my
survival and coping mechanism but we
also want to figure out how to live a
life here
and I can't think of anyone who I'd want
to hold a conversation about how to do
such a thing than with you
I've been working out a lot of stuff
with my own life and I appreciate my own
family and my mom so much but when I was
reading this book at night and coming
home from work which we take with us so
anyone who compartmentalizes you know
personal and professional my hat's off
to you because usually it bleeds all
together for me and I would
hold your book to my chest at night
and I would wish that I was in your
family that you were my mom or my sister
and I I feel like everybody feels like
that my friend who do you see yourself
as to everybody you know I I have never
thought about that in that way I mean I
want to be a support to people to the
extent that I can that's one of the
reasons why I wrote the light we carry
because I was you know in a time of
uncertainty when I wrote this book in
the middle of the quarantine
um
tucked away with my family my girls had
come home from college they were afraid
like everybody else and I had to think
about what tools I had to lean on to get
through because one of the reasons why
I'm so candid is that people think that
folks in high places have all the
answers we do not we have a lot of the
same fears all we have are the tools
that we develop over the course of the
lifetime so I thought well let me put
this in a book so I did my best to put
as much of the wisdom that I've
accumulated over this almost 60 years
yes January 60.
um
and to share some of those insights with
my friends my sisters the people who
look up to me the people who are asking
those questions so I don't think it's
one thing it's kind of like whatever
somebody needs to be able to hear
something that can help them well
speaking of tools I would like to ask
you one for myself yes funny story I was
with
um
Michelle okay thank you
I was with Michelle uh one morning I was
lucky enough to moderate a beautiful
discussion with children about something
me and my family love waffle and mochi
um the Netflix the Netflix show food
it's a food Adventure we connected it
was everything I leave I go about my day
and that evening I'm at the George
Clooney uh Georgian Amal Clooney
Foundation gala Awards
and I see you across the room you're
with Meryl Streep John Oliver George
Clooney
um and I think like a few other of the
top functioning people in the planet
and I sat there
and I didn't know how to walk up to you
oh I was like I don't I think that's
just too intimidating of a circle well
you probably would have been blocked by
an agent or something too so I'm glad
you didn't try and feel the hand of an
agent but you could have you know well
I'm single for seven years so maybe it
wouldn't have been a bad thing but
[Applause]
and a lot of them are cute
[Music]